big city struggling to deal with
lawlessness shocking video out of san
francisco shows young children being
forced to navigate their way through
homeless people doing drugs
after getting off a school bus
in los angeles olympic medalist kim
glass was almost blinded and left with
multiple facial fractures after she was
attacked with a metal pipe
by a homeless person
before i knew it a big
metal bolt
like pipe
hit me
hit me
right here here i just it happened so
fast he literally flung it from the
street so he was not even close to me at
all
um
kind of took me down and out and um
there's a lot of mentally ill people on
these streets right now shouldn't have
to be fearful when you walk but it's
true
and so you guys just be safe
dana these are these stories are
disturbing they're not just in los
angeles and san francisco but i watched
kim glass her tell the story of the last
few days on television maybe even on
your show what are your thoughts about
this well i
i was devastated for her and i'm
thankful that she was willing to
she's a beautiful woman who is willing
to say here's what happened to me and
this is look at what i look like um and
she's
despondent over it in terms of
what's happening in her city she doesn't
want to be afraid to go to work so
because these stories there's so many of
them
no a lot of people are feeling this way
i think and what i thought was just
incredible is that video of the san
francisco kids
going through the drug den walking
having to walk through the drug den that
looks like a movie set yeah but i would
play that on a loop over and over and
this is what i don't understand how does
gavin newsom think he's actually going
to run
absolutely when this is happening right
under his nose like that's your hometown
like this is happening he's in florida
it's not happening but yeah he wants to
run against uh desantis okay
telling people to leave florida to come
to california yeah and i really admire
that i admire the people that are
putting this being willing to put this
on video so that we can all see it
because it makes it more real and more
likely hopefully that something could be
done about it jesse you've talked i mean
greg you've talked a lot about we all
look like
i know i don't know what to do with him
anymore either yeah don't meet don't
don't make me take out the mean potatoes
but the the
you've talked a lot about the need for
mental institutions and mental health
institutions
arresting these people who are
committing these kinds of crimes do they
need to be in a mental institution or is
it a big jail or is it some hybrid or
what how should we think about it i mean
honestly there needs to be a
they need to be compelled to be
institutionalized and i we've we've
abdicated that moral responsibility we
somehow believe that it's
someone's right to be a harm to others
and a harm to themselves we didn't used
to think that way that changed in the
60s also in normal times incidents like
what happened to the olympic athlete
they would captivate and change society
you know you think about the bernie
goetz moment you think about the that
utah tourist that was killed in new york
but i think the media decides that
unless you can pin the violence on law
enforcement or trump supporters it
really isn't that exciting to them and
this stuff is just you know uh you know
that's just another thing it'll go away
i mean we you know we we didn't even
touch on i don't know if you guys did it
yesterday on philly that horrible
horrible
with the children but um the real
ugliness a lot of this is against women
you know when you think about it it's
like where are the feminists you know
your gender is getting its butt kicked
on the street and in sports and in
dictionaries and what are you doing
nothing
your honor
you know i think the saddest part of
this story harold is the kids that had
to see that they had to witness people
shooting up
people buying drugs maybe dead on the
street in the tenderloin district in san
francisco and dana had it absolutely
right
uh this guy wants to run for president
when he's got a city that's a mess like
that and california that the this kim
glass she was she's gorgeous absolutely
gorgeous yeah what we're experiencing
now is just it's a basic takedown of
america
where law and order doesn't matter
anymore and what they want to do in in
san francisco is they now want community
workers and not police to respond to
low-level uh calls regarding emergency
calls regarding the homeless i mean can
you imagine kim glass gets hit with that
metal pipe and you know these homeless
they're shooting up who's got dirty
needles who's in the middle of a sale
and they want a community worker to go
in and not a cop i mean we're just
asking for it to get worse and it's it's
it's just
it's just horrible and by and by the way
that right now i just want to say one
more thing
alvin bragg you know is now talking
about he's going to let um he's going to
let the bodega owner
dismiss the charges i don't know what's
taking him so long he's got a video the
video's right there he's got a record of
both guys make a decision but he has
made a decision that he's not going to
charge the woman who started the whole
thing who was furious who went home got
her boyfriend claimed that alba the
owner of the bodega was rude to her and
stabbed him three times that's an
assault in the second degree in new york
and they're not going to charge him this
alvin bragg i mean there's violent crime
is going on and people are just
accepting it but she's a widow now
i don't think they were married
you had something on earlier dana before
coming to jesse where it talked about
san francisco had school boards out
there renaming schools and taking stuff
like 500 000
and they painted basically destroyed a
mural of george washington crazy instead
of dealing with like by maybe buy some
books or uh you know computers fix your
circumstances even take that money to
help get the homeless off the street
whatever that was about what do you
think
a lot of that was federal taxpayer
dollars as well my thoughts are this is
you can never listen to what a liberal
says they say that they care
they say that they're gonna give you
free college they're gonna give you your
kid free
daycare they're gonna give you free
health care their entire governing
philosophy is we're going to help people
and provide a safety net
do they ever help a homeless person they
don't even talk about them they let them
fester and decay in filth and drug
addiction
and die in the streets
and they say they care about kids and
they have kids marching over
zombies to school they say they care
about women women gets slammed in the
face with the pipe they don't talk about
that they say they care about the
environment you don't mean liberals i
know
they don't buy carbon offsets they don't
buy teslas you see them they litter you
see libs in manhattan like this just
throw the butts right there they don't
care about the environment
don't listen to what they say watch what
they do
and i'm watching you there are some
amazing generalities in there
here we go again
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now